Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube là Excel bài số
16 các thủ thuật Excel 2 phần 3/4 trước
khi vào bài học ngày hôm nay mình sẽ dạy
các câu hỏi của bài tập số 15 hôm trước
nhé cái câu hỏi của bài tập số 15 như
sau ở đây mình có danh sách là năng cái
sản phẩm mình sẽ làm các cách để tạo cái
danh sách xổ xuống nhá thì một cái là
liệu mình sẽ tạo cái danh sách xổ xuống
thông thường và một cái phần là tạo cái
danh sách thủ tướng thông minh thì đầu
tiên mình sẽ tạo nên danh sách xổ xuống
Thông thường nhá Thì cái Cách thứ nhất
là mình sẽ gõ trực tiếp không ạ Và Cách
thứ hai là mí sẽ chọn cái vùng cái sách
thì gọi trực tiếp thì họ sẽ tích vào cái
ô mà các bạn cần tạo với danh sách xổ
xuống ở đây là cái od4 đúng ạ sau đó các
bạn vào thẻ đa ta lại các bạn sẽ vào vai
đa tăng validation ra ở cái thẻ xuất
tinh Á cái mục yellow các bạn sẽ chọn
cho mình là list đấy
Ê thằng sợ đây thì bạn sẽ gõ cho mình
các các sản phẩm thì bạn chú nhắc cái
phần mà gọi trực tiếp này thì thông
thường nó chỉ làm với các trường hợp và
mình gọi ít thôi Ví dụ như là chọn giới
tính cho chắc anh mà nhiều thì các bạn
cũng không nên dùng cách này nhá Đấy thì
con sẽ gọi trực tiếp vào đây là gái xe
một Đấy cần phải ra và các bạn có tiếp
cái sản phẩm Thứ hai là điện cái CO2 sẽ
cứ như vậy bạn gọi em gái sao lăng nhé
lại sẹo ba đúng không ạ sau khi các bạn
gõ xong mẹ từ gãy xem một đến gãy cho 5
nhá Còn thử nhé Nó phải cách nhau bằng
cái dấu phẩy này thì gọi Bống ok đấy thì
như vậy thì okay bố này nó ta đã có một
cái danh sách xổ xuống rồi là năm cái
sản phẩm từ gãy sẽ một đến gái xấu lắm
đấy các bạn có thể chọn một cái sản phẩm
bất kỳ nhé xanh cái Cách thứ hai của cái
phần danh sách xổ xuống Thông thường nhé
là
em chọn từ cái vùng danh sách trúng ạ Họ
sự tích vào đây các bạn vào thẻ ra ta
Các bạn chọn hiện đa tạng validation ở
cái mục setting này cái một câu lô các
bạn sẽ chọn cho mình là lít đấy các bạn
sẽ tích vào cái phần sọ này nhá Sau đó
các bạn Bun đen danh sách các sản phẩm
của bạn sức là điện từ 34 đến 38 ở đây
này đấy các bạn xem bấm ok để thì tương
tự thì cái kết quả đây nó sẽ ra là gì
năm cái sản phẩm từ lãi sang một đến gãy
65 và các bạn sẽ thích chọn một cái sản
phẩm bất kỳ rất là hay Okay tiếp theo
mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn là cách tạo
vài danh sách xổ số thông minh thì tại
vì sao mình phải dùng với cách này thì
nếu Nhưng mà khi các bạn thêm các cây
sản phẩm ví dụ như là gì gãy 6 đây lại
nhé đấy thì diện với cách thông thường
này nó sẽ không cập nhật Cái bạn gái cho
Sáu Các bạn nhìn thấy này Đấy nó chỉ đến
gái xem năm thôi Cái này không Thế nó
chỉ đến gái sang năm thôi mà nó không
đến cái sáu đấy thì ở cái phần thông
minh này mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn nhắc
nó sẽ tự động nó sẽ cập nhật thêm các cá
khi mà các bạn điền vào dưới này thì đầu
tiên mình sẽ tạo bằng cái diện bằng cách
thay bồ và cái hàng Inax thì đầu tiên
mình phải tạo cái thai bổ cho cái vùng
dữ liệu nhé các bạn sẽ Bôi đen cái nguồn
dữ liệu là từ cái oa ba đến thì 8 sẽ là
toàn bộ vùng dữ liệu là danh sách các
sản phẩm và cả các tiêu đề nữa nhé sau
đó thì các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ Insert này
các bạn chọn Thay bồ đấy thì nó sẽ hiện
một cái cửa sổ là diện khuấy tiếp theo
bổ này các bạn thấy chưa cái vùng dưới
lượng mà mình Bôi đen đã nhấp nháy này
thư viện từ 3 đến tháng để cọ xát tích
Chọn ok lại các bạn có thể chọn cái màu
hiển thị cho các thầy bùa này nhá và các
bạn có thể đặt tên nhá tên mặc định thay
bộ một thì các bạn có thể để cái tên này
cũng được hoặc các bạn thích thì các bạn
có thể đặt tên đây nếu như bạn nào không
muốn đặt tên thì bạn cứ để tên mặc định
ví dụ mình đổi tên là dễ các Bôi đen Ví
dụ như để làm diện sp sẽ là sản phẩm đến
các bạn enter thì như vậy mình đã tạo
xong một cái table là sp rồi đấy
khi bạn tích vào đây này các bạn chọn
FPT thì như vậy toàn bộ cái phần sản
phẩm nó đã được lựa chọn ở ra khá là hay
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ dùng cái hàm indirect
Nhát Để mình làm cái phần diện và phần
danh sách cả xúc động này các bạn sẽ
tích vào cái ô d11 nhá sau đó Gọi vào
thẻ đa ta để các bạn sẽ vào để
data-validation thì ở cái thằng setting
nhá Đi ngủ con lô các bạn vẫn chọn cho
mình là gì là lít đấy Tiếp theo là cái
phần sở để ở phần sạc các bạn làm công
thức này có sẽ bằng điện indirect Đúng
không các bạn xem hỏng hóa đơn nha các
bạn mở ngoặc kép ra nhé Thấy thì có sẽ
điền cái tên thuê bồ vào lúc nãy mình
Đạt đúng không cái thấy buồn mình đã có
lẽ là sp Đúng không các bạn hãy nhớ là
cái tên Thay bồ này nhá lại nếu như mình
đặt cái thấy buồn nào thì sẽ điền vào
đây là tên của cây bồ đấy là tên nó sẽ
nằm ở trong cái phần mở ngoặc kép vào nó
ghép này để gọi sau đó hóa đơn này nữa
Bây giờ chọn sẽ định Ok nhé thì cảm thấy
là danh sách xổ xuống ở đây nó đã có
diện 5 cái bạn gái xem bây giờ xử thêm
các bạn gái sắc
A và giả sử gái sáu bảy nữa đi nhé phải
gặp enter thì như vậy cái phần danh sách
sản phẩm vào đây bạn thấy chưa nó đắt
cập nhật thì bạn gái gái sáu và gái Sao
mặt lại rất là hai ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ lưu
lại coi như là mình sẽ không thêm với
bạn gái cho 6 và gái cho bài này Ok sang
Cách thứ hai là gì bạn Mình chế tạo cái
danh sách xổ xuống bằng cách thay bồ và
cái lên thì lúc nãy mình đã có cái thai
bù lại este rồi đúng không Bây giờ mình
sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu này sau đó
bạn sẽ lên kém Nhưng bóc này có thích
Vừa nãy con sẽ đặt tên cho nó nhạc Ví dụ
mình đặt tên là việc sản phẩm Thầy Bùi
hạ thế Mình sẽ đặt tên cho cái vùng dữ
liệu mình chọn ở đây là sp và thay bồ
cũng có sẽ bấm enter lại thì toàn thoát
ra ngoài Các bạn lên cái lên bóc này các
bạn chọn FPT bù lại thì toàn bộ cái vùng
dữ liệu mà mình đặt bên nó lại được lựa
chọn lại đúng không Đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ
tạo cái danh sách xổ xuống này các bạn
thích vào đây các bạn vào thẻ ra ta các
bạn vào để data-validation lại
xem xét tin nhắn một câu lâu bạn sẽ chọn
theo mình biết cái phần soạn nha các bạn
sẽ bằng này các bạn sẽ bấm cho mình cái
thứ nhất 3 đấy thì các phím tắt F3 nó sẽ
hiện việc các cái nên mà nó vẫn mình đặc
cũng đặt làm việc FPT bồ đúng không Bạn
xem bấm ok các bạn xem bấm ok đợi thì
như vậy Ở với Nên nó đã có danh sách xổ
xuống rồi không ạ Đây thì lúc nãy mình
Bôi đen thì mình chọn mình chọn cả cái
tiêu đề là sản phẩm dân gian là gì À cái
danh sách xổ số này nó sẽ có cả sản phẩm
đúng không Bây giờ mình sẽ bỏ cái chữ
sản phẩm đi đúng không còn sẽ vào cái
thẻ phòng lời nhá các bạn vào cái lên đi
chơi đấy thì lúc đấy mình đã đặt cái tên
lẽ bên tay bồng a cọ xích một đây Các
bạn bấm ăn ít đấy thì mình sẽ chọn này ạ
Lúc đấy mình chọn sản phẩm thì bây giờ
các bạn Bôi đen Cái free Vertu các bạn
Xóa lên và các bạn chọn lại nhá Đấy mình
sẽ chọn từ cái diện từ cái ô A4 đến A80
đấy Bạn thấy nhé các bạn bấm ok để tao
sẽ bấm Ok thì bây giờ cái danh sách
anh ấy chứ giờ làm mất cái thằng sản
phẩm đi rồi rất là hai ạ bây giờ ví dụ
mình thêm với bạn gái sau nhá cho enter
đấy Bạn thích vào đây bạn thấy này đây
đã có gái sáu rất là hai ạ Mình sẽ lưu
lại nhé Cái Cách thứ ba là gì mình sẽ
dùng cái hàng offset và cái hàng cao ra
rồi ok các bạn sẽ tích vào phải ô thì OD
15 để các bạn thì các bạn tạo danh sách
xổ xuống nhá tại các bạn và kẻ đa ta Các
bạn chọn việc data-validation đấy trong
cái thẻ xét sinh này một câu lâu có thể
chọn cho mình biết là cái phần sọt các
bạn sẽ làm không giúp nha con sẽ bằng
đấy ạ đấy còn sử dụng cái mô xe này cho
Asha mở ngoặc đơn ra thì thành phần đầu
tiên của khách hàng access là cái ô tham
chiếu đó thì họ sẽ tích vào ví dụ mình
tích và hiểu đầu tiên là cái ô sản phẩm
nên là cái tiêu đề là cái ua3 lại đó
phải tiếp Thép là gì Là cái số hàng mà
các bạn cần dịch xuống đúng không miễn
dịch không hàng
anh cái số cột mà có cần gì không phải
của mình sẽ dịch không cột phẩm tiếp
theo là gì Là cái xô mà các bạn lựa chọn
đúng không Thì ôm mình lựa chọn e gì
mình sẽ dùng cái hòm cao AH các bạn mở
ngoặc đơn giản và các bạn thích chọn cả
cái cuộn anh à rất là những cái hàm cao
AH nó đến xem là bao nhiêu ô mà có chứa
dữ liệu là nó Họ sẽ đóng ngoặc lại và
bạn - một Tại sao lại - 1 rất là mình sẽ
- cái ô mà là cái thằng tiêu đề là sản
phẩm đây ạ Đấy có thật đóng mặc lại sau
cái hào bác xem này nhá để tạo sự tích
ok thì như vậy Ở đây nó đã tạo cái danh
sách xổ xuống Bột đấy thì cái này nó sẽ
có một cái sai là diện là mẹ nó lại là
sản phẩm rất là đáng nhé là cái sản phẩm
này là phải thay bằng gái sẽ ôm một và
cái cuối cùng phải là gái xấu lắm thế
nào nó phải tuần tự đúng không Đây thì
như vậy nó sai ở cái phần mà lúc nãy
mình đã dùng cái hành access sang bây
giờ còn tích vào ô này các bạn vào đấy ạ
Các bạn vẫn vào thẻ ra các bạn vào data
validation
ở phía nơi mình sẽ sửa công thức nhé Đây
thì vì cái hàm áp xe trong lễ mình đặt
cái ô ra phần là Cái ba thì cho nên thì
cái số hàng nó dịch xuống phải là một
hành đúng ạ Còn nếu như mà có thai O3
bằng A4 ý thì cái số một này sẽ phải vẫn
là số 0 Nếu như các bạn chọn cái phần là
cái sản phẩm thì diện các bạn phải dịch
số một chất làm thì mình sẽ chọn cái sản
phẩm đầu tiên là đây lại còn sẽ bấm ok
Bây giờ còn sẽ kiểm tra nhá Đấy Như vậy
là từ lãi sang một đến bãi xe 5 dùng rất
là hai ạ Ví dụ mình đổi thành điện ngày
sao
i9000 hạ thế h + enter để các sợi vào
đây bạn thấy này đấy có gái xấu xí máy
vẫn rất là hai ạ Ok như vậy là mình đã
xong cái phần diện danh sách xổ xuống
đây nhá các bạn sẽ đóng ạ Bây giờ mình
sẽ vào bài tập ngày hôm nay là bài số 16
trong bài học ngày hôm nay mình sẽ hướng
dẫn các bạn là ba cái thủ thuật đầu tiên
là thể autocorrect thứ hai là gì co giãn
chữ vừa với cả ô và thứ ba là ngăn không
cho nhập trùng đầu tiên mình sẽ vào cái
phần autocorrect nhá mình sẽ làm luôn
nhé Thì trong lúc vừa làm sẽ giải thích
nó sẽ dễ hiểu hơn là mình giải thích nhá
Đây thì đầu tiên các bạn sẽ các bạn vào
cái thẻ pha lại các bạn chọn về Epson à
anh Hải tặng chủ nhà ở đây mình đã hướng
dẫn cái suối rồi Các bạn chọn cái Lucy
nhà đợi thì ở bên phải này các bạn thấy
chứ nó là ô tô có cách Epson có ích vào
đây để anh thì ở đây nó đã có một số cái
ô tô có lại các sân bằng tiếng Anh rồi
cái làm thông thường nếu như người ta
hay gõ chữ oa đây này Đấy thì lớn nhưng
gõ thế này thì nó sẽ đổi thành cái gì
chữ bị iOS để nó đúng pháp không Đây bây
giờ giả sử Mình muốn thay cái chữ gì chứ
gái Excel mình gọi chữ g ví dụ gọi E R
đi Đấy mình sẽ đổi cái chữ gọi l là bằng
chữ Excel thì bạn sẽ vào đấy phần nguyên
này gắn gõ là gà gáy xem đã xem bấm f
đấy Bạn thấy chứ Thì như vậy nó sẽ thêm
một cái quý chắc mà các điểm dưới đây ví
dụ làm gà west hạn thế là gà này w.d.
lại mình muốn thay bằng word lại cảm sẽ
Bống ép tiếp
Ừ thì như vậy mình đã thêm hai cái quy
tắc là diện GL là gái xe và gw là gà wed
của họ sẽ bấm ok đấy bạn sẽ bảo OK nhé
bây giờ ví dụ là gì họ tên ví dụ là gái
sang một đơn vị là gì Các bạn sẽ gọi GL
các bạn enter đây Thì như vậy Cái người
l nó sẽ lập tức đổi thành gánh xem họ
thì cũng rất là hạn ví dụ ở đây là gì
thằng nào cũng gà post 1 nhé đơn vị là
gì cả chỉ cần gõ g WD và các enter đấy
thì lập tức nó sẽ đổi thành dạng gà wed
cảm thấy rất là hai ạ bây giờ để xóa các
phần autocard này thì con sẽ làm ngược
lại ạ Các bạn lại vào thẻ file Các bạn
chọn options Tại mình sẽ vào đấy lu sinh
này các bạn sẽ vào auto click xin đại ca
City với quy tắc mà các bạn ạ Lúc lên
nhé đại ca sự tích về đây Bạn có thể gõ
cho girl này Vậy thì nó chịu Gọi E là
đây Bạn thích một đây và các bạn xem bấm
cái Delete này đi
chị sẽ ăn nó xoáy tắt này rồi Tiếp theo
các bạn tích vào đây còn gọi chị g tép
này cả đang xuống này cây nhà cô nó sẽ ở
đây đâu đấy giờ WD ở đây này các bạn sẽ
phân tích và được v lít đi Các bạn bấm
ok ok Bây giờ bạn sẽ gõ là chị gọi l nhá
Nó sẽ không ra Tại vì lúc đấy mình nó
xóa cái ô tô có ở kia rồi đúng không ạ
Các bạn đi hết đi sang thủ thuật thứ hai
là mình sẽ tự động co giãn nhé Thì cái
này ứng dụng rất nhiều ở cái việc mà các
bạn in ấn đấy thì nếu như mà các bạn in
nhá chọn sẽ vào cái thẻ lưu đi lại còn
sẽ chọn cái gì ạ chọn cái phatra lại cảm
thấy cái vùng dữ liệu ở đây nhá Nó đang
ở một trang đúng không nếu như bạn muốn
cái những cái ô này các bạn rộng ra một
tí nữa để nó hiện cái số đấy thì nó lại
chàng sang cái trang này để bạn thấy rất
là không Hay đúng không ạ Bây giờ mình
sẽ lưu lại nhé bạn sẽ vào cái lau mờ đi
bây giờ mình làm
có những cái ôm mà nó có dấu xanh này nó
sẽ hiện là cái số liệu và mình sẽ chấp
nhận là diện nó sẽ ko nhỏ với cứ chữ lại
Bố bạn đây để đảm bảo là cái vùng in của
mình nó sẽ không bị tràn sang một trang
mới đúng không đấy thì cách nào là Thiện
đầu tiên mình phải mô đen Những Cái Ô mà
mình muốn tự động co giãn đúng không ở
đây là diệt tháng 2 này đấy các bạn giữ
cần chôn nhé để mình Bôi đen các tháng
tiếp theo các bạn vẫn giữ control mà Đấy
sau đó bạn nhấn phải nhá các bạn chọn
phóng Marcel để chọn sẽ vào cái thẻ
Doraemon và các bạn chọn nào dễ sinh tố
phim này để bạn sẽ bấm ok như vậy các ô
mình lựa chọn lúc đấy nó sẽ tự động co
giãn nhá để nó sẽ hiện được cái số lượng
đó anh cảm thấy rằng khi cuộn con lại
lại này đấy thì cái số này nó sẽ tự động
nó sẽ rạp với cỡ chữ đi này còn thế rất
là hai ạ Cái này chẳng hạn nha Bây giờ
mình lại tăng ạ Vậy thì nó sẽ lại về cỡ
chữ mặc định này có bạn tăng nhiều ra để
hạn chế nhắc thì nó vẫn về cái cứ chữ
mặc định cho
Ừ thì bạn ko nhỏ lại thì nó sẽ giảm hết
cỡ chữ đi để làm vẫn nhận số liệu ở đây
cho các bạn thấy khá là hay đấy lại cách
là mình điện mình sẽ co dãn cái có chữ
cứ động nhé ví dụ tiếp theo là mình sẽ
ngăn nhiễm trùng cái này cũng khá là hay
đấy Bây giờ giả sử mình có những cái dữ
liệu là mã nhân viên này thì có cái
thông tin họ tên ngày sinh quê quán tại
ghi chú chán thế nhá Bây giờ mình sẽ
muốn là cái chắc của mình yêu mãi nhân
viên này mình không được phép nhập trùng
Giả sử có cái mã nhân viên là nhân viên
001 này nhá Nếu những bạn nào mà nhập cá
nhân viên 001 đây nó sẽ báo lỗi ngay đấy
Còn nếu như bạn Nhập nhân viên khác thì
ok thì để làm việc này các bạn làm như
sau nhé Bạn sẽ chọn cái vùng dữ liệu Ví
dụ mình chọn cả cái cột bên này đi đấy
các bạn vào thẻ data các bạn vào data
validation nhất trong cái thẻ setting
này cái mục câu lâu các bạn sẽ chọn cho
mình là cá tầm đấy Bà Rịa Ở cái phần
Phong và lưu này các bạn sẽ gõ cho mình
công thức nhé các bạn sẽ làm gì ạ Các
bạn sẽ bằng cái hàm cao
ở Hòa Lạc KF đều được nhé ví dụ Kali vẽ
lên các bạn hoặc đơn giản thì cái vùng
điều kiện ở diện các bạn sẽ tích chọn cả
cái cột b này đúng ạ phẩy cái điều kiện
là gì ạ vì ở đây mình Chọn toàn bộ cái
cả cái cột bên này đúng không cho nên
cái điều kiện ở đây các bạn sẽ thích vào
cái ô đầu tiên là ob1 đấy các bạn xem đó
ngoặc đơn điều kiện làm việc nhỏ hơn A
đợi thì bạn hiểu cái câu này nghĩa là gì
Tức là những cái ôm mà các bạn Nhập vào
nó phải không trùng nhau trùng nhau Tức
là nó sẽ lớn hơn hoặc bằng hai đúng
không mà ở đây mình chỉ cho phép nó nhỏ
hơn hay thôi cho nên nếu như trùng nhau
đấy thì nó sẽ bằng hai hoặc là lớn hơn
hay thì nó sẽ báo lỗi luôn Tức là nó sẽ
ngăn không cho bạn để cùng nhau đấy
ngoài ra các bạn có thể tích vào cái
phần Grow Plus này còn thực hiện thông
báo nhé Nếu như mà nhập trùng nhau thì
quan hiện thông báo này điện Ví dụ mình
thông báo Họ đã có cái mã nhân viên này
đúng không Các bạn thấy không rất là hay
tức mà nó hiện cả cái thông báo luôn các
bạn sân bấm ok đấy bây giờ ví dụ nhập cá
nhân viên 002 thì nó không trùng đúng
không Thì nó
Ừ Ok nó không cảnh báo gì cả ví dụ mình
nhập nhân viên 001 các bạn enter đấy cậu
thấy chứ nó làm hiện một cái báo lỗi
ngay ở đây là gì đã có cái mã nhân viên
này đây thì có bạn sẽ bấm cancel để các
bạn không nhập nhá Còn nếu như bạn với
trai thì nó sẽ cho quan nhập lại ví dụ
là nhân viên 002 hả Thế nhá các bạn
enter thì nó phục báo lỗi ngay tại vì
cái mã nhân viên không hoa đã có đây rồi
đúng không đấy các bạn Lisa ví dụ như là
mã nhân viên 003 lại thì ok đấy đấy là
cái cách các bạn có thể ngăn nhiệt trùng
nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ xem cái câu hỏi về
nhà nhé Ok cái câu hỏi về nhà nó cũng
khá là nâng cao đấy Ở đây nhá mình yêu
cầu là diện cái mã công ty và cái số vốn
nó phải thỏa mãn điều kiện điều kiện số
vốn có phải là kiểu số nhá Còn cái mã
công ty thì nó phải có 2 cái yêu cầu thứ
nhất là cái ký dự đầu tiên là ký tự tách
Còn ba cái ký tự sau là ký tự số
ý thì cái ví dụ của mình là gì g123 đấy
đấy là cái chắc để các chất tạo cho cái
rĩa các bạn sẽ kiểm soát được việc nhập
dữ liệu nhé khoảng cái số vốn thì gọi
nhập vào phải là thiểu số nếu như bạn
Nhật Tech Ví dụ như đoạn nghiệm lái xe
lẽ sẽ không cho nhập lại đây là cái bạn
tưởng về nhà trong các bạn nhé Ok như
vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học ngày hôm
nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi các
bạn nhé Đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật video
mới nhất của gà cũng như chia sẻ giúp
mọi người có học xem nhé Xin chào và hẹn
gặp lại ở